il vanne fedorov à paresser sur ces
images la semaine dernière peu de temps
avant son arrestation par les troupes
russes le vendredi 11 mars le maire de
la ville de mélie topol a finalement été
libéré mercredi peu après le président
ukrainien s'est entretenu avec lui au
téléphone
[Musique]
kiev a fait savoir ce jeudi que la
libération de fedorov avait été obtenue
en échange de 9 soldats russes
prisonniers le maire de 33 ans de la
ville de la région de sapporo de vie
dans le sud est de l'ukraine désormais
occupée par les russes avaient été
accusés de terrorisme
ils auraient été emmenés dans la ville
de louhansk dans la région séparatiste
du même nom est remplacé à la tête de la
municipalité par cette femme galina
daniltchenko jusque là sa principale
opposante
mais après son enlèvement la population
de milito paul avait multiplié les
manifestations contre les forces
d'occupation
dimanche seuil even matveïev autre maire
d'une ville située 80 km plus au nord ni
repos rhône et qui a été à son tour
enlevés